- Our first guest today
is one of our favorites
partly because he always
brings a new baby animal
every time he's here.
I love this.
His new show coincidentally,
is called "Animal Control"
and it premieres tonight on Fox.
Give it up for Joel McHale, everybody.
(audience applauding)
- I told ya.
Keep it coming.
(audience applauding)
Look at this.
It's a sloth.
- I'm so mad for you right now.
Hi.
- You can't pet his head though.
- No?
- Well...
- Okay.
- But here, you can pet here.
- Is he gonna bite me?
- He'll go, like, "It's food."
He'll think it's food.
Hi.
Hey, look.
Look.
- [Kelly] Don't you want to snuggle?
You're takin' him home.
Congratulations, you won the sloth.
- I know, I already worn my team.
Am I gonna take a sloth home?
I don't know.
- Yeah.
- Oh, my gosh.
- Do you wanna hold him?
- I really do.
- All right, here we go.
- Well, hi.
Hello.
- This is just food,
which is lettuce and vodka.
- Totally.
- Here if you sit, I'll give them to you.
- Oh, my God, I'm so excited.
- This is a tree sloth, everybody.
As opposed to the-
- As opposed to...?
- A ground sloth, which are extinct.
Oh, that's a great fun fact.
So, yeah, if you, uh...
Yeah, you can give him a little-
Oh, look at this.
Check this out, guys.
- I'm so happy.
- Look at that.
Can you get a read on that?
Kelly, can't even see the joke on my arms.
- [Kelly] I can't.
Wait.
Eight appearance?
- [Joel] Yeah.
(audience applauds)
Thank you.
- This is your eighth appearance?
- Yeah.
- Oh, my God.
I love when you come.
- [Joel] This is so great.
Kelly doesn't care.
This is great 'cause we're like-
Aw.
- [Kelly] Who cares about
Joel when there's animals.
- [Joel] There you go.
Look at that, guys.
Have you ever seen anything this cute?
And a lot of people think
they're, you know, they smell.
They don't.
- They don't smell.
- They smell like jasmine.
They don't smell like jasmine.
You just walked right into it.
- [Kelly] Probably because
it's hard to clean themselves.
They're so slow about it.
- They're a little slow, but you know,
they are three times
stronger than a human being.
And I am not kidding.
They can basically hang
from a tree indefinitely.
- Oh, my gosh.
- No joke.
- So wait, so what happens
on the show "Animal Control?"
What happens?
- I don't know, I can't remember.
I think it takes place in space.
No, it's called "Animal Control."
And it's about the people
that come to your...
if you call them, they're like,
there's a raccoon or a coyote
or a snake in your backyard
or somebody's got an illegal rabbit farm
or something,
we come and take those things away.
It's an office... office...
A comedy, and the cast is fantastic.
Obviously.
- That's gotta be fun.
You go to work and
there's animals everyday.
- Yeah.
- What's the coolest
animal that's been on set
that you were like, oh,
that was a cool experience.
- The tarantula was pretty great.
- [Kelly] I like tarantulas.
- Yeah.
- I heard that, wait, did
it crawl on your face?
- I let it crawl on my face.
Do we have... there it is, yeah.
That is a seven-year-old
tarantula named Gretchen.
I'm not kidding.
And if you stop thinking...
people are like, isn't it scary?
It just feels like somebody
just very lightly crawling
across your face with fangs that big.
- Yeah.
But not poisonous.
- No, they say it feels like a bee sting.
Which it didn't sting me.
That particular tarantula is
handled by children every day.
And I'm not kidding.
- I'm not kidding.
I grew up...
When I was young, I went to this school
and there were just tarantulas everywhere.
Like in the whole...
It was a very poor area.
And literally there were tarantulas
and they would come outta the holes.
I'm not kidding, we'd
play with 'em at recess.
- They're like, "Sorry,
we don't have a big toy."
Just play with the tarantula.
- But I'm telling you what's
interesting though for kids,
like you could have put the
most wonderful playground
ever out there, but you know,
it's awesome that its like,
tarantulas are out there.
- And they live in the ground.
- Yeah, there were giant holes everywhere.
And literally that's what I
remember from that school.
- What was the school mascot?
- Bees, Luella Merrett.
Bees.
But you know what, the tarantula
sting feels like a bee.
So we weren't far off.
I listened.
- Where was the school?
- Fort Worth, Texas.
So has this new show made
you wanna get more pets?
Because every time you're here,
I feel like you almost get
in trouble with your wife
'cause you wanna bring an animal home?
- Yeah, I brought home a Clydesdale horse.
- Did you really?
- No!
- Oh.
- Clydesdales are like awesome.
- Yes, they're huge though.
- They're massive.
One of the largest horse breeds, guys.
- You're like Nat Geo.
- Well, there was a puppy that I was like,
I've gotta find a way to bring this home.
And then I told my wife and she was like,
"Don't come home because
you've already brought-"
We have three dogs and a rabbit.
And she's like, "We have enough."
We have a small-
- I have two dogs and three rabbits.
And a hamster.
It's a lot.
- I can't top that.
Well, I got two teenagers.
- I have a six and eight-year-old.
- Ugh.
Okay.
- Wait, speaking of teenagers, he's 18.
Eddie, right?
- Yes, my son turned 18.
- So wait, 18.
Do you feel like...
You have an adult kid.
Do you feel old?
This is what I wanna ask.
- Yes, I feel very old.
I bought him a pack of
cigarettes, just for fun.
I'm kidding.
Smoking is terrible for you.
It was cigars and, uh...
No.
- Classy.
- It's very weird.
Yeah, there he is.
He looks really happy to be at Stonehenge.
That's where we were.
- I've never done that.
That's cool.
- It is cool.
- Yeah.
Except when the kids
get there, they're like,
"Wow."
"Rocks."
You'd probably much rather
have some tarantulas.
Yeah, now he's like a man.
I mean he's got the hair of a man.
Got hair everywhere.
And yeah, he smells like a man.
- Strange, yeah.
Total adult, yeah.
- You'll see.
And it'll happen before you know it.
- I know.
- I mean, these people
grew before our very eyes.
- Just now.
- They start out a fun kids audience.
And now look at 'em.
- It was romper room and now it's-
- How do the clothes still
fit them is the real question.
- Wait, so you and your wife,
this is amazing,
26th anniversary, did
y'all just celebrated?
- Well, last summer, 26.
We're coming up to 27.
- That's incredible.
(audience applauding)
- There we are.
- Y'all are so cute.
Do you still...
At this point, do you still do gifts?
I mean, what do you get
each other at this point?
- I got her a sloth and-
- She's so stoked about it.
- We have not...
It's one of those things
where she's tried a bunch
of times to buy me clothes
and she's like, "I'm not gonna try."
But for my birthday, she got me...
You know Brian Cox from
"Succession" on HBO?
- Yeah.
- We got a cameo of him
telling me to (bleep) off.
(Kelly laughs)
I kind of cried a little bit.
I was like this is the greatest thing
I've ever received as a gift.
- What a perfect counterpart for you.
- She was like, "Here you go."
- I bought her a coat last week
where I just kind of saw it
and I was like, "This looks good."
And I purchased it.
It arrived and she was like,
"This actually works."
And it was a surprise.
- It's hard to do
clothes for other people.
- It is, yeah.
- And she's always like,
"Oh, this is actually good."
As if... everything else was kind of-
- Crap.
- Crappy.
And so she likes it, so yeah.
We suck at dating.
Our first date was in like in '93.
So...
Yeah, when the photographer
was not even born.
And yeah, we look at each other,
we're like, where did all this-?
- [Kelly] Time?
To this day, when I get
in bed with her, I'm like,
"I'm in bed with a lady."
- With my lady friend.
- Look at her.
Woo, what happened?
- That's why you're still together.
That's awesome.
At least you're not looking
over going, "You again."
- She does that.
Her eyes can roll all the way over.
And she doesn't really...
Well, she laughs at like every 50th joke.
And she'll be like, "Oh, that was funny."
- Because she's used to you.
- Well, yes.
- She probably knows what
joke you're gonna say.
- Well, sometimes.
Or I'm just relentlessly annoying.
But I, like, dated a
girl once that laughed
at everything I said.
And I was like, this is weird.
I shouldn't be winning this much.
- I know, but you're funny.
That's on you, not her.
- Yeah.
That's your fault.
- Yeah, that was Nicole Kidman.
- Just like Jimmy Fallon
when he didn't know he was on a date.
Did you see that?
- No.
- Oh, my god.
This is a real thing.
Nicole Kidman was on- did y'all see that?
And she was like, "No, we were on a date."
And he was like, "Wait, what?"
And he had no idea he was on
a date with Nicole Kidman.
- Really?
- The best.
I swear to you.
Google it.
- And she was like, this is going...
well?
- And then she was like,
he was there in tennis
shoes and a ball cap.
It was hilarious.
- What did he think the
evening was gonna be
if you're just gonna hang out
with Nicole Kidman?
- I can't remember.
But he really messed that one up, right?
Like, I don't know.
To not know you're on a date.
- Yeah, that seems-
- Maybe he just thought
it was so far-fetched.
He was like, this is not-
- I wish I had that confidence.
- So I have to ask about
the "Community" movie
that was announced for Peacock.
This is incredible.
What can you tell me?
Can you tell me something?
I wanna know.
- You guys even know what that is?
- Yes.
- Yes, we do.
- Alright.
Yeah, we're doing the community movie
and I can make the big
announcement of what it's about.
I'm kidding.
I'm never gonna tell any of you.
No, I would never.
I'm not gonna reveal anything.
- No fun spoiler.
- It's a lot like Star Wars.
One of them.
One of the many.
It's like that.
Yes, we're doing it.
I'm so excited.
And the cast is excited.
Everyone's back and we're
just gonna be great.
- That's cool.
- Other than that, I can't
tell you anything else.
- All right.
- Other than, everyone dies at the end.
Like in "Hamlet," everyone's dead.
- Everyone dies, what a tease.